one last problem in this section let's
see problem number 16 after the first
term each term in a sequence is 3
greater than one-third the preceding
term so if I to write that so if I were
to say n you know the the N of I plus 1
so is equal to the preceding term it's
times one-third plus 3 and all I'm
saying is if I have a term right you
know save the ith term is n n sub I I
take one third of it and add 3 to get
the next term that's all that's just
fancy notation for that if T is the
first term of the sequence and T does
not equal 0 so so this is T I probably
even have to write this ignore this if
this confuses you so T is the first term
what's the next term I'm going to be
it's going to be one-third times T plus
three so it's going to be T over three
plus three and they're going to say and
then we could keep going but they just
want to know what is the ratio of the
second term to the first term so what is
the ratio of this to this well the ratio
is T over 3 plus 3 2 T right and that's
the same thing as t / 3 T over 3 plus 3
times 1 over T that's the same thing as
T over 3 times 1 over T plus 3 times 1
over T it is distributed the one over T
these cancel out so that equals
one-third plus three over tea and that
doesn't look like any of the choices I
see so we probably have to find a common
denominator so that lets say the common
denominator is 3 t just multiply the two
one third is the same thing as t / 3 t +
3 / t is the same thing as 9 over 3t
alright I just want to apply the top and
the bottom by three so T over T plus 9
over 3 t.t plus 9 over 3 T is choice C
and you could even ignore this really
the hard part is just
is well the hard part isn't even this
the hard part is actually just you know
you might end up with something like
this and they're like well I don't see
that choice and then you have to realize
i'll have to find a common denominator
to get to this where the common
denominator is 3t well that's it that's
a very short video I'll see you in the
next SI t test or on the next sh t test
I'll see